welcome to machine learning with Python
my name is Richard Kirchner and I'm with
simply learned you might be new to
machine learning or Python or maybe
you're concerned that they're difficult
and complicated to learn don't worry by
the end of this tutorial we'll go over
the basics and have you writing a couple
of simple scripts to use machine
learning in Python before we dive in
let's take a look of our agenda for
today we're gonna start with why use
machine learning and applications of
machine learning we'll follow that up
with how machine learning works and
machine learning workflow once we've
gotten through these four points we'll
show you the tool anaconda this allows
you to do some Python scripting and
where to download that from and then
we'll get back into more detail as to
exactly what kinds of machine learning
there are and finally we'll do a linear
regression demo and a k-means clustering
demo where you actually get to write a
couple scripts and get your hands dirty
and do some Python work and finally
we'll wrap it up with a use case weather
analysis so let's get started with the
first two bullet points why use machine
learning and applications of machine
learning
why use machine learning before we get
too deep into this let's look at a
simple use now we'll use the example of
PayPal which uses machine learning to
detect fraud so what PayPal does is it
uses this different machine learning
tools and before I started using machine
learning a lot of people were getting by
with a lot of scams and then once they
figured it out they said hey we need a
tool in here that's gonna be automated
and easy to use and reliable and so they
found the machine learning tools came in
and then they're able to stop the
different fraud now we're gonna answer
why use machine learning after we look
at applications in machine learning
applications of machine learning in the
applications of machine learning we have
search engine results we have voice
recognition we have number plate
recognition we have dream reader if you
think hard enough you'll find that this
small sampling is just the beginning
from automated cars to scientific
discoveries any of these things are all
part of today's world of machine
earning and let's take a look at the
search engine the first one imagine if
you were at Google or Bing or yahoo.com
and someone typed it you typed in a
search to one of those and that goes
across to somebody and they look at it
they have to read it then they go to the
library they look up the information
they come back and then they type back
the answer to you which might or might
not be correct depending on which person
you got one of the things we notice
right off the bat is that's not what
happens nowadays nowadays you give very
reliable information you get it fast
it's automated and as time goes on and
we get more information the search
engine returns better and better results
this is true a voice recognition where
it gets better better recognizing what
we're saying and able to transcribe that
for any of your Google commands or home
devices where they recognize your voice
or maybe it's Siri if it's iPhone we see
that in number recognition we've seen
that in being able to read things back
to us like dream reader does with news
things so as we're looking at
applications of machine learning we want
to take away that the use of machine
learning or why use machine learning is
because it helps make life easier
it helps our processes be more
consistent and reliable now that we have
an understanding of why machine learning
let's go take a look at how machine
learning works we have phase one which
is learning that's broken up into three
different steps the first step is you
need to clean the data and format data
that's your pre-processing what does
that mean well computers nowadays aren't
too smart when it comes to figuring out
the difference between a picture or text
when you send it in so the first thing
you do is usually clean the data so that
all your pictures are in one file and
your text is being processed separately
and that's all part of the
pre-processing
if you try to process text like you do a
picture you're not gonna get the right
answer and vice versa
once you've pre-processed the data and
you have it nicely cleaned then we're
gonna go in and start learning take that
data and learn from it and there's what
they call supervised and unsupervised
data on the learning and we'll talk
about that more later on there's even a
third field in there and finally we went
into testing so once you've gone through
this process you've trained your
learning so it works correctly you need
to test it making sure you get the right
answers out of it once you've gone
through all that then you move to Phase
two which is actually using it or
putting it into commercial use and that
is to do a prediction and on there you
now have your train model and your new
data come together and output it's going
to be a prediction of what you're
looking for we see that in the form of
predicted data let's take this and let's
see what it looks like as a workflow so
let's take a look at the machine
learning workflow if you are doing any
project the first thing you want to do
is define an objective not just machine
learning but in life in general in
machine learning once you defined the
objective then you have to prepare the
data number in our last slide we talked
about cleaning the data well that's
where you're preparing the data you want
to make sure you understand what's
coming in make sure that you have the
right data mixed with each other
make sure you have the proper schema
that way you know what tools to use once
you've prepared the data and you have an
idea of what's coming in you need to go
ahead and collect the data once you've
collected the data you select the
appropriate algorithm to work with that
data and then you take that selected
algorithm and you pass it to train the
model now once you've done a train on
the model you want to test it and what
happens with the test is it might come
out incorrect so you might have to
change how you train the model and if
that doesn't work you might have to go
back and say okay I selected the wrong
algorithm to do this let's pick a new
one that's gonna work and once you've
gone through all of that and you have a
test model that works then you can put
it out for production and start using it
to predict things you know there we've
taken a couple looks at the steps to
setting up machine learning and the
process let's take a little detour we're
gonna need a tool to do this in so let's
look at downloading anaconda now
anaconda which utilizes jupiter
notebooks it's one of the top tools used
by data scientists it's one of my
favorite ones it's also very easy and
simple so that anybody who's developing
program or script can use it to get
right in and jump ahead now anaconda
which we might also reference as jupiter
notebooks because as part of that and
we'll show you in just a minute it's
part of that group
programs and applications is a wonderful
tool and it is used by both people who
are just beginning and starting out in
Python or data science all the way to
advanced people and professionals it's a
very powerful tool to test your scripts
in and it's very easy to use to download
anaconda you'll want to go to WWE
anaconda comm once you're on that page
you'll see a button on there says
download anaconda this will take you to
another page where you can select the
version of anaconda and the version of
python you want to use with it if you're
just new and starting with python you'll
want to use version 3.6 which is the
most current version for people have
been using Python and they have all
their modules they might need you can
also download Python version 2.7 and
once you're in anaconda you can also add
new versions on there if you need to
once you've downloaded the appropriate
version of anaconda you'll want to go
ahead and open up the installation file
by double clicking on it and go through
the installation you'll see here the
welcome to anaconda 5.0 0.1 64 big setup
this wizard will guide you through the
different steps throughout the wizard
unless you have a special setup you can
go ahead and just let it select the
defaults and once you get to the end you
can go ahead and click on install to
start the installation once you have
installed anaconda into your computer
you'll be able to find anaconda prompt
which will open up a window in this
window you'll type Jupiter notebook
that's jup ytr
space notebook you might also have the
jupiter notebook startup in there too
which will do this automatically for you
jupiter notebook will then open up your
default browser window well you'll then
have your running anaconda through
Jupiter setup and you'll be able to
select new and python you'll see on the
upper right hand corner you'll have a
new button and I'll have a drop-down
where you then select python 3 or if you
installed it python 2.7
once you've opened up your new Python
notebook you'll have a line you can type
in and you might want to just try quick
script in Python print in this case
you'll say print this line
we'll be printed and then when you hit
the play button you'll see this line
will be printed let me show you these
last two steps in my own Jupiter
notebook and anaconda as you can see
here I have my web page open and it's
opened up to Jupiter when I go to the
upper right-hand corner where it says
new I click on that it gets a pulldown
menu and then I click on Python 3 and it
opens up the Python 3 once I'm in here I
can now type in on the top line print
brackets quotes this will print below
when I go up and hit the play button it
executes this line of code this will
print below I then have another line
below and whatever I've run above
whenever I ran in the first line if I
put in like x equals 5 that information
carries on down so I can continue to
program I can put down print let's do
hello world very common in the
programming world and it prints hello
world let's look at types of machine
learning we'll see here there's three
types of machine learning and we'll
start with supervised learning
if remember before we had mentioned
supervised learning and unsupervised
learning and I said there was a third
one which is reinforcement learning so
let's look a little deeper what is
supervised learning supervised learning
machine learning model learns from the
past input and makes future prediction
as output types of supervised learning
the two main kinds of supervised
learning that are used today is
classification and regression
classification is concerned with
building models that separate data into
distinct classes as you can see the guy
in the left he has yes/no very common
true/false
they can have more than one two classes
but usually you see a lot of
classification where it's a two
decisions to make let this person have a
loan or don't let him have a loan or in
the cases earlier let them bill to
paypal or don't let them build a paypal
common algorithm used the two common
ones are decision tree and support
vector machine regression based on
previous input data the machine predicts
continuous output value and you can see
here we have three green bars and you
can probably grasp the fifth one's gonna
look like
algorithms used our linear regression
and polynomial regression though they're
the two most common ones although there
are certainly many more and we haven't
touched upon neural networks which is a
whole nother group of machine learning
tools that include both of these let's
look at supervised learning
classification in this example we have
passed data where we might have images
of girls and boys and these different
images go into the model training and
once it's gotten once we've tested that
and we made sure it works correctly and
it's what we want then we can take the
new data which would be a new image in
this case of a girl and the prediction
comes out and labels it as a girl then
let us take a look at the classification
decision tree and this one we're making
a weekend plan and the plan is going to
depend on numerous choices that come up
the first one is are the parents
visiting if the parents are visiting yes
then we'll probably watch a movie if no
then it's gonna depend on the weather if
the weather is rainy we'll probably stay
inside and do something if it's sunny
we'll probably go outside and play
tennis so you can see this basic setup
generates a tree based on what's going
on in different information coming in
let's take a look now at supervised
learning regression in this model we see
we have the past data coming in in this
case it's the amount of rainfall it
might be how much how warm it is what
the temperature is based on what day it
is
this information comes in and it says ok
Thursday the temperature was 55
Wednesday it was 52 degrees and then it
rained when he hit 39 degrees on the
following day now we've trained this
model and tested it and once it's been
tested we can now then put that same
information that's happened like the
last three days and tried to predict
what today's weather is going to be
based on that information that came in
this is a good view of supervised
learning the regression model let's look
at another example of supervised
learning regression in this one we're
going to take a look at real estate very
common use of linear regression and
let's say we're in a market and we know
that a small house sold for one dollar
amount and a larger house sold for a
larger dollar amount maybe we have a
number of houses we plotted on this
and then we want to know how much of the
house I'm about to sell worth based on
its size and so we'll take a line and
we'll plot these points and we'll draw a
line through those points that's why
it's called linear and we'll look at the
house we're in and then we can guess
where it occurs on that line how much
it's going to sell for now I don't know
if if you're like me you're probably
ready to roll up your sleeves and start
doing some scripting and doing some
hands-on so let's jump into the fun part
and see what this looks like in Python
code so here we go let's jump in with
our linear regression demo and start
learning a little scripting in Python
first before we do any of the work in
the Python we have to import all the
tools we need now the basic programming
like X plus y is part of your basic
Python scripting language but people
built these modules that have all the
different tools and I'm already
pre-built so we don't want to rebuild
all those we wanted them to do the work
for us so we'll start by doing the
importing we're gonna import the mat
plot library pie plot and you'll see it
is as PLT that's a very common to use
the PLT term for our mat plot library
pie plot and then from numpy we're gonna
import as NP that's a number python is
whether it's abbreviation for and numpy
is a way of working with our arrays so
that they can take our data and format
it in a way that our learning kit or
scikit-learn will be able to use and
then from the SK learn or sq yeah the SK
learn we're gonna import datasets and
the linear model and the linear model
uses data sets that's where you have to
import that and the linear model is what
we're actually using to do our linear
regression in it makes it very easy and
then once we've imported their different
tools we're gonna use we want to go
ahead and load a data set to work with
so we've created a data set here called
house price and you'll see here it's
labeled 245 312 279 and then we have
another array called size and that one
set to 1400 1600 1700 1875 so on
and they correspond with each other so
the first house price is 245 and that
corresponds with the size of a house of
about 1400 square feet and each one of
those is 10 items long and that's very
important because this is like an XY
plot so we want to make sure that we
have an X for every Y and then we're
gonna reshape the input to your
regression and this is a little
confusing so I'm going to come back to
here in just a second and we're gonna
set size 2 equals MP now remember NP
came from numpy numpy as in peace we
imported the numpy for dealing with our
data and reshaping it in this case we're
gonna reshape the size and we're gonna
reshape it in what they call format of
minus 1 comma 1 so let's do a quick
break out and see what this looks like
in jupiter in your anaconda jupiter
notebook and also see what the size two
is about so here I pasted the code up to
now in the jupiter notebook and i'm
gonna hit the Run button up here and
you'll see that it comes down and i
actually added a line here that says
print size so when we have the size
array and i print that size array you'll
see it's 1400 comma 1600 comma 1700 and
then we're going to take and print the
size to array the one that we've
reshaped and let's go ahead and run that
and see what that looks like and you can
compare the two the first one is just an
array or a row of data and we've taken
that data row and the minus one means
it's going to be that forms brackets
around everything so it's one large
array and then each row is only gonna
have one item in it that's what that one
stands for so we've created 10 rows with
one item each and an array just so you
can see what this looks like I'm gonna
change this to 10 and run it and you'll
see that I now create an array with one
row of 10 items and then we're going to
do this with 5 and if I run that I
create an array with two rows with 5
items each
and then we're gonna change this to
three and just a quick gasp what do you
think will happen with three this is a
trick question because three doesn't go
into 10 and so when I run it with three
I'll get an error because it cannot
break it into three can't break it into
equal parts with three pieces in each
row now for this particular example I'm
gonna go ahead and keep this as one
because we do want it to be one item per
each row let's go back to the the
regression model that we're working on
now that we have all our data set up and
all our imports done we need to go ahead
and create a variable that is defined
for the linear model and that's where
this first line comes in we take in our
EGR for regression and we set that equal
to the linear model dot linear
regression and then brackets all that
does is that takes that module that we
brought in and assigns it to a variable
once we've assigned it to a variable we
want to go ahead and do what they call
fit and that takes the data we have in
this case size 2 and then the house
price and that's going to fit it to a
linear regression model it's going to
see how close you can get to that line
and then we're gonna print the intercept
and we're gonna print the coefficient
and let's take a look at that you'll see
in here where there's a coefficient
output and the intercept cut output
I'm gonna go ahead and do a breakaway at
this point and show you what that looks
like so you can see what's going on now
here we are back in our Anaconda Jupiter
notebook and I don't I can put this down
below and this is one of the nice things
about this is I keep my script separate
so I can test each piece one at a time
and let's put that code we just did in
there and then I'm going to run it and
you'll see here where it prints out the
coefficient and the intercept so we're
going to put in sighs new equals 1400
and price equals the size new times the
regression coefficient plus the
regression intercept and when I go up
here and I hit the Run button on that oh
we want to print the price you'll see
that I get a value out so for 1400 that
line is going to generate a number 251
point
9 - another way to do this and this is
very important to notice although we'll
be using the formula in here so you see
what's going on is you can also do
regressed predict size new and you'll
see in here that I've taken the size new
and I've did the double brackets around
it because that's the format it needs to
see in there it needs to see a single
row single column and let's run that and
you'll see gives the same answer now
generally when you're doing just a
simple linear regression you can use a
formula but when you get to much more
complicated machine learning you'll see
that predict comes in and is much more
important to use it instead of using the
actual formula now let's go ahead and
get back to where we were now that we've
done our step out and we're gonna come
in here and we're gonna create a
definition now you can create your own
definitions and they can be called from
your program and run over and over again
in this case our def de f4 definition is
called graph so whenever we type in
graph and we put in two values in that
graph these lines are going to run and
you'll see in here we have in brackets
formula and X underscore range and
whenever these are put in here the first
thing it does is it takes an X and it
sets to equal to an NP array a numpy
array remember we imported a numpy array
as NP and it does it to X range what
that is doing right there when you see
that specific set up is it's going to
convert that X range array coming in
into a numpy array Y is going to be an
evaluation of the formula so we're going
to be putting a formula in here and
we're going to eval
and that's what Y is going to be equal
to and then finally we want to go ahead
and take our PLT plot and add those
numbers at X Y in there
so basically we're taking the x value
from our array coming in and then we're
going to evaluate with the formula we're
going to send in there also finally
we're gonna use that definition we just
created and you'll see right here says
graph and then we're going to send it
the following formula the regression
coefficient times X plus the regression
intercept and then we're sending at a
range of 1,000 to 27
now what that range does with that
particular Python command does is it
creates a list of numbers is 1,000 1,001
1,002 1,003
and so on and so on all the way to 2700
and if you remember that it's going to
take those numbers and it's going to
plot each one of those based on the
formula that we've created through our
regression coefficient and regression
intercept you'll see right back up here
where we did the definition and this is
where we have that eval the formula
coming in so once we've done that and
has put all those dots on our PLT or
plot then we're going to add one more
set up on there we're gonna do a scatter
plot and on there we're gonna put the
size the house price remember our
original data we're gonna put that right
in there and then we're gonna put those
in black dots and then finally we want
to go ahead and add some labels to our
plot and you can do that simply by doing
the PLT dot y label and in there in
brackets and then in single quotes
you'll see house price and then you'll
plot the X label with size of house and
then finally we want to see it so we'll
do the plot dot show command and as you
can see below our definition created
that nice blue line down the middle and
then there's the actual data that was
used to generate that line with the
difference that we originally imported
in time for a quick break out let's go
ahead and see what that looks like in
our anaconda Jupiter notebook let's put
that last piece of code down here and I
just haven't have it saved so I'll paste
it right in there
come up here to the Run and you can see
just like we expect it it's generated
this nice graphed with the blue line and
you can easily see the different plots
from our original data that generated
that linear regression model now that
we've gone through a basic set up a
linear regression and you see now to do
some basic plotting you can always play
with those numbers and try some
different numbers in there or create
your own and see what you can create
let's go ahead and move on to the next
topic unsupervised learning let's take a
closer look to see exactly what that
means unsupervised learning means
that the machine is learning using
unlabeled input and allows the algorithm
to act on that information without
guidance so if you remember when we did
the supervised learning before we had an
answer and we trained it before we
started putting in unknowing data and
this one we don't have an answer we're
gonna let the algorithm create the
answers for us in unsupervised learning
we take a lot of raw data we put it into
the algorithm and you can see in this
case we're using pyramids and cubes and
ovals and then the algorithm looks at
that data and creates its own categories
or creates its own ideas of what that
outputs gonna look like we don't have to
tell it what a pyramid is or what a cube
is it guesses the major types of
unsupervised learning are clustering and
Association clustering is used for
analyzing and grouping data which does
not include pre label class or even a
class attribute at all
the most common algorithm is the k-means
- other common algorithms used for
unsupervised clustering as a
hierarchical clustering and the hidden
Markov model Association discovers a
probability of the co-occurrence of
items in a collection the most common
used algorithm for that is the
appropriate algorithm and there's also
the FP growth algorithm let's take a
closer look at unsupervised learning in
clustering and the basic idea of
clustering is we're going to take
similar items and cluster them together
and move dissimilar items into their own
group in the k-means clustering the
first thing we need to do is randomly
initialize two points called the cluster
centroids and usually you pick them
anywhere on the graph you want to do
them R and Elise are not in the same
place now
based upon the distance from the orange
cluster of the centroid or the green
cluster centroid ill group itself into
that particular group once it's grouped
itself into that particular group we
want to make some adjustments we want to
move the centroids around just a little
bit and then regroup them so they're
more optimized we're going to keep
repeating that and we're going to
iterate that till the cluster centroids
stop changing their positions and become
static
in other words when the point seemed to
form best around the two centroids and
seem to have their own groups very
distinct groups once the clusters become
static there's no more adjusting or
moving around that algorithm is said to
be converged you'll hear the term
conversed in most machine learning so we
talked about our machine learning tools
converged means it's done
it's finally found to point a solid
point and then you can start testing it
and then using it in your real-world
usage or commercial use before we look
at the actual script let's take a look
at a case study and what that looks like
in real life
let's say you have a hotel chain and
wants to establish its new delivery
centers across the city in the most
optimized way now I don't know about you
but if I owned which I don't but if I
owned a hotel chain I would want to
maximize a position for the best way of
making money and the least amount of
cost so in this case some of the
possible challenges that are going to
come up as we want to analyze the areas
from where the food is being ordered
frequently to figure out the optimum
number of hotels required to cover the
city area to figure out the optimal
hotel locations to minimize the distance
between the hotel and the delivery
points this gives you an idea of one of
the uses that they start they used four
different clustering on there you start
clustering these different things
together until you find where is the
optimal place to place a hotel now we're
not going to dig up all the data on
hotels and the logistics of movement to
different areas not for a basic learning
example definitely something you'd want
to dig into in a situation like this but
let's keep it simple let's roll up our
sleeves and let's see what the k-means
clustering looks like in Python script
so here we are with our demo on k-means
clustering using Python and just like
before we want to start by importing
numpy as NP very standard for using our
numpy arrays and we want to import our
map plot library PI plot as p LT again
very standard because that's how we're
gonna plot the data so we can see what
it looks like and then from the mat plot
library we're also going to
port style and we're gonna use a style
called ggplot now don't worry too much
about that that just makes it look nicer
and there's a lot of options we're not
going to go into all the different
options you have in the map plot library
you have to look that up but it
certainly has a lot of uses in there
this just gives you an idea that there
is more to it than just a map plot
library and finally from the SK learned
cluster we're gonna import k-means once
we've done all our imports we want to go
ahead and set up some data to use and
play with so we're just gonna take some
random numbers in this case and I'm
gonna set X equal to one five one point
five eight one nine and we're gonna set
y equal to two eight one point eight
eight point six and eleven now remember
the one and the two go together so it's
1 comma 2 X 1 y 2 X 5 y 8 and then when
we take and we do a scatter plot of that
you can see it puts a nice little set of
dots across different our graphs you
have a nice output of it let's just do a
quick break away so you can see what
that looks like in the jupiter notebook
we go ahead and put that code in here
we'll comment and hit the run script
button or run cell slick below and you
can see if does a nice plot just like we
showed you so now that we see what the
data looks like the next step just like
we did before we have to convert the
data to an NP array or a numpy array and
you'll see instead of shaping it which
we could have done we went ahead and
just created a double bracket so you can
see what it looks like if you don't
shape it and you'll see there that we
put a brackets around and then you have
each point 1 comma 2 5 comma 8 one point
5 comma 1 point 8 so on and so on and
we're going to label this as X and then
the next step as we go ahead and create
our cluster variable and in this case we
put a call that k-means all lowercase
and you'll see that it equals k-means
which is the module we brought in and
we're going to send it a variable to it
called in clusters or in underscore
clusters and we're going to set it equal
to 2 that's how many clusters we want to
make now that is one of the challenges
when working with k-means is guessing
how many clusters you want
that's why it's nice to always plot the
data first because then you can guess
what the cluster how many clusters you
want and then set it accordingly and
then once we've done that we very simply
do a k-means dot fit X and that takes
our X data that we just plot it and fits
it to the k-means and creates those
different pieces of data we were looking
at earlier so here you see it we can set
a variable called centroids and we can
set it equal to our k-means variable dot
cluster sinners and that's part of the
k-means module is you have cluster
centers and you have labels so we can
create both our centroids and our labels
and when we print our centroids and we
print our labels you'll see down here
the output the output is the first
centroid is going to be located at one
point one six six comma one point four
six six six that's where the first point
is and then the second centroids at the
seven point three three three and nine
and then the labels that tells it each
of those different pieces of data we put
in it says which centroid that's going
to go with so the first one is zero and
the second one goes with one which is
the second centroid zero one zero one
and that's how it groups those different
points of data to keep a nice continuity
let's go ahead and do a breakout and
let's go into our Anaconda Jupiter
notebook and you can see here we did our
final show on the scroll down here and
pasted this last piece of code in here
and then we'll go up and hit the Run
button and you'll see right there is our
two centroids
and there's our labels we have for each
of our data points one of the things I'd
like you to notice at this point and
take away from this is it in both the
linear regression and in the k-means
clustering there's not a whole lot of
programming it's very easy so if you
were scared to do a clustering you can
see that within a couple lines of code
you can do the clustering and now we're
gonna go ahead and show you how to print
the clusters on to a graph so let's move
on here to the plotting and
visualization of the output and we're
gonna go ahead and do the colors again
in this case you can see we use kind of
a standard color scheme a lot of times
when you do a project you want to pick
the same color scheme or general color
scheme
so that everything kind of goes together
on there and in here we're gonna go
through I through the range of the
length of X so we're going to look at
each of these X variables and then we're
going to print the coordinate the
coordinate of X of I and the label so we
know which coordinate goes with which
label and then we're actually going to
plot them for each one we're gonna add
that to the PLT plot and then once we've
done that just to kind of make it fun so
you can see where those centroids are
we're also going to add the scatter plot
and put the two centroids on those plot
and then once we've done that we'll go
ahead and do a show so you can see what
that looks like now when you're looking
at this some of this might look a little
confusing so let's break down just a
couple of these pieces the first one I
want us to look at is the PLT dot plot
in here we have X I of 0 and X I of 1
now remember we have to plot X's and we
have to plot wise we have to send those
as individual arrays one way to do that
is to do X of I remember I is in range
of length of X so it goes 0 1 2 3 4 5 so
we do we look at the first one and we
look at just the value 0 and we look at
the second one and just the value 1
this is abbreviation and it's actually
sending all of the x coordinates in one
array and all the x coordinates in the
second array and it's plotting each one
of those dots and then for the colors we
want the colors to match the label so if
it had a label of 0 it's going to be
green you can see that g dot up there
being in the in the very first position
the zero position and if it has a 1 it's
going to be red which is the first
position or you actually count your rays
from 0 1 2 3 so it's a zero position and
the one position and then finally we've
added a marker size equals 10 that is
something you have to play with when
you're playing with the plots usually
tends a good size for a marker but you
might find that you need more points a
20 point or a 5 point depending on what
you're publishing it to and how you want
that to luck and then second part I want
you to look a little closer at is the
PLT scatter and you'll see here we have
centroids and then it does the colon
come
zero and so when it does that and again
is the abbreviation looking at just the
first part of the zero in that array and
then the centroid colon one is going to
be the second centroid remember we go 0
1 not 1 2 in our arrays and then we set
the marker equal to X because instead of
being a point or a dot we want this the
centroids to show up we want to look
differently and we made them larger so
we put s equals 150 and the reason we
use s equals 150 instead of marker size
is because that's a font size setup and
then finally we have line widths and
z-order don't worry too much about those
you could actually take those out and it
would still work just fine but we're
gonna leave those in because it makes it
look a little nicer and finally you have
the plot show and we put those all
together you'll see that it prints out
the coordinates and each of the labels
that go with that coordinates and on the
right you have a nice view of what that
looks like we have the three dots that
go with the first centroid or the
centroid in the zero position in the
array and we have the three dots that go
with the centroid that's in the one
position or the other centroid in there
in our k-means clustering which remember
we set to do two separate clusters now
wouldn't be right if we didn't do a
quick break out and show you what this
looks like in the python jupiter
notebook so here we are in our notebook
I'm gonna put the code in here I'm gonna
go up here to run script and as you can
see we have our coordinates all printed
out and the nice graph down below with
our two centroids on it now that you've
seen the scripting involved for the
program let's take a quick look at a
simple use of how this works and we'll
just use like what is used in commercial
use here we have a customer who's going
out and buying bread milk an apple looks
like some lettuce in the back another
customer who's brought some water an
apple some bread and if we have a third
customer who picks up a loaf of bread
what do you think they would buy with
that bread well you'd be right to guess
if I was looking at this I didn't know
anything else I would guess that they're
gonna buy an apple with it and this is
great if you're in a grocery store and
you want to put stuff together that
helps people you're marketing to them so
they're gonna buy what goes with it so
you put peanut butter next to jelly
because people buy peanut butter
probably gonna buy jelly people who
might buy noodles might buy sauce to go
with it so this kind of grouping some of
it might be very intuitive some of it
you might never a thought other things
that go together and so this is great
and very powerful tool used in marketing
today let's talk about reinforcement
learning if you remember from before we
looked at supervised learning where we
had data and answers put in there we
trained it from our experiences we had
unsupervised learning where we're
categorizing things and finding out what
goes together now we're gonna look in
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning involves teaching the machine
to think for itself based on its past
action reward so here's kind of a fun
example we have Mario Brothers who can
move left right or up and down and as
you go through the game it performs an
action and in that action maybe it gets
the reward of the mushroom because it
went up and jumped and landed on the
mushroom or performed an action where it
landed on the villain and in this case
you lose a life your punishment so this
is reinforcement learning we start doing
trying to go towards what rewards us and
we move away from punishment and that
uses the feedback from whatever we just
did to learn what we're gonna do next
and so the algorithms most commonly used
with this is q-learning
temporal difference TD deep adversarial
networks now that we've looked at the
three major areas of machine learning
and we've done scripting and two of them
we're going to take a look at the use
case study of weather analysis to give
you an overview of what goes into
setting up one of these databases and
what a work environment looks like in a
lot of cases the first thing is we want
to state with the problem is the problem
is to predict the weather conditions
using machine learning and the possible
challenges that come up are to identify
the areas which are exposed to rainfall
considering the temperature and pressure
as parameters k-means
algorithm will identify the regions
which are expecting heavy rainfall so
this could be really important if you're
worried about flooding especially in
today's world we've had a lot of floods
of recent and so the data set that was
being used in this has 3,000 entries and
they assume a K equals 3 in this case we
had light rainfall medium rainfall and
heavy rainfall and so the first thing is
they downloaded the data set with the
3,000 entries and once we take those
3,000 entries let's take a look at the
script behind the weather analysis now
we're doing something a little different
here and if you don't understand
everything going on that's ok and I'll
explain why in just a second so first we
have our importing of the libraries a
lot of that should be familiar from our
other two scripts we did we have our map
plot library in line it's a little bit
different but we have from copy import
deep copy deep copy allows us to copy
arrays instead of just using pointers
because a lot of times in Python when
you say an array a equals array B it
points to it but we want to actually
copy all the different variables into a
that's what deep copy does you should
recognize import numpy as NP we've added
a new one in here you haven't seen
before which is import pandas as PD very
commonly used for importing data into
your program from a file and then we
have our from mat plot library import
pie plot as PLT again very common we've
seen that now a couple of times and then
we have two different formats for the
plot that we're using in here we have PL
TRC params and we're setting the figure
size that just limits the size of the
figure don't worry too much about it's
one of those things you kind of play
with when you start playing with graphs
is you notice that there's figure size
and there's other settings in there and
then there's and because we're using
very large data it's important to bring
it down to a smaller size otherwise
they'll take up your whole screen and
then we have a plot style in use and
again we went with the GG plot on here
now the one thing I want you to notice
on here that's missing from when we did
k-means before was the came
library from SK learn well we're gonna
show you here and this is why I don't
want you worry too much if you get a
little lost is what it looks like when
you don't use the SK learn now remember
the SK learn took a couple lines we told
that how many centroids we needed and
then we let it do the rest of the work
so in this example I'm gonna walk you
through I'm gonna show you what it looks
like if you don't use it the SK learn
clustering program in there let's take a
look at the data and in this case they
used panda to import the data this is a
wonderful tool so if you have saves a
CSV file comma separated variables with
your data in it you can now easily
import that into your program using the
PD the Panda and in here you can see
that panda recognizes that there is the
header line and then it also recognizes
how much data is in there and breaks it
up for you so in this case we did print
data
shape and you'll see that there's 3000
different entries in this data set that
they used for this example and when we
do and it has the two the two means
there's two columns and that's
represented in here with a 2.0 7 2 3 4 5
and the minus 3.2 4 1 6 9 3 and when you
print the head out data dot head and you
can just type in if you're in Jupiter
you type in data head once you've read
your data in it'll print out what you
see here just the the header on there
and the line number and the different
data associated with it so you have your
temperature difference your pressure
difference and you have line 0 1 2 3 4
and the head only prints out the first
four lines kind of a nice way just a
glance and see what kind of data you're
gonna look at and this is a nice
introduction into Panda a really
wonderful tool in the Python library now
once this has been imported again we're
still looking at stuff you've seen that
should make a lot of sense f1 equals
data and because of the way panda
imports it it labels the data so I can
very easily say f1 equals data
temperature difference dot values
that's what pandas does that's all panda
on there and f2 equals data pressure
differences
values so basically I've created my XY
in this case it's F 1 and F 2 and then
we're going to come down here and we're
going to take x equals NPR a that's your
numpy array and we're going to create a
list and we've done something just a
little different here you'll see where
it says zip F 1 comma F 2 that takes and
that combines the F 1 F 2 so you have a
list of 1 you know the first values the
second value is and so on we'll come
back to that in just a minute here in
the next setup and then of course we
just go ahead and plot the f1 and the f2
or the XY the temperature difference
versus a pressure difference and they
set the color for black and the size is
7 so we've got is a size 7 and you if
you look at it the first thing you
notice is it groups into three nice
general groups of data and that means it
when you're going to start doing the
k-means kind of clustering you want to
do it two three that's pretty clear on
there when you look at that and they
were gonna take a little detour and this
is where it starts to get a little
confusing and this is where I don't want
you to worry too much about it because
we're showing you what's under the hood
of k-means this is what's going on the
first thing is we create a definition
which is a distance and this is just a
distance between two points and so if
you have two points that are you know XY
three comma four five comma six if you
remember from your geometry Euclidean
distance just draws a triangle and it's
that line of that long edge of the
triangle that's all this is calculating
on here and then of course we already
talked about number of clusters so k
equals three and then if you remember
with k-means it generated the centroids
for you automatically well under the
hood what is happening as it goes in
there and it creates the x coordinate
and it creates a random one in this case
it creates three of them and it creates
three random Y coordinates and it takes
and does it between zero and the max
value of x minus 20 in this case they
don't have to be minus 20 and usually
don't start at zero but that will work
fine for this example like I said this
is under the hood so if it looks if you
confused on there don't worry you don't
need to know this if you're actually
using the k-means or the SK learn on
there but knowing what is doing is
important and in this case we put them
into a numpy array so that's what that
NP for numpy and then there's a dot
random dot random integer so we're going
to create a random integer and it's
between 0 and the NP max and we're
creating 3 of those so it's our array
three wide of three random numbers and
we do the same thing for Y and then
finally we create our centroids and we
do that by combining the X and the y and
that's where this NPR a list zip C of X
C of Y comes in it combines each of the
X and the Y's and pairs them together
and then you have your D type equals NP
dot float 32 well float means it's a
floating decimal that's all that means
is we're turning it from an integer to a
decimal now there's an actual you gotta
be a little careful on Python because
float means something a little different
than decimal but for the very basics you
usually use float with most of the
machine learning and you just kind of
assume that that's gonna be have a
decimal point and the value has a
floating decimal on it that's where the
float comes from and then if we print C
for the centroids you'll see on the
right hand side we have our three
centroids that we've generated with rent
with a random integer turned into a
float variable now once we've done that
we're gonna go ahead and plot a scatter
plot of F 1 and F 2 original data and
we're gonna do that and the C again C
just stands for color so the color
number oh five oh five oh five is a very
dark color it looks pretty black to me
and we're gonna plot scatter the CX and
CY CX was all the X centroid markers and
CY is the array of the Y's and we're
gonna put those as stars and if you
squint and and kind of do a find the
star in the picture you'll find the
three stars in there one of them sticks
way out there in the upper right if you
look just a little bit below it there's
another one and to the left and between
those two is the third one in the middle
of that top cluster and again you see C
equals G so we set the color green so
they're easy to
find so then we need to go ahead and
store the values of the centroids so
when it updates it changes those shapes
around
so we have our centroid Oh old equals
the number array of zeros of C shape
that's just kicking our current C
centroids and moving them into a stored
array so we can get back to it if we
need to when we need to and we create
cluster labels in p zeros and they say
lengths of X so you have 0 1 2 that's
all that's doing is creating 0 1 2 in
the numpy array then we have an error
function which is the distance between
the new centroid and the old centroid
and if you remember we created the
Euclidean distance formula so you have
like your new XY coordinates for the new
centroid and your old XY coordinates for
the old centroid and that's going to
create an error what's the error between
them what's the distance between them
and so we initial that error and then
we're going to create a loop and the
while loop is a Python command and it
says while error is not equal to 0 so
long as we have an error long as it's
not equal to 0 I want you to do what's
below and then during that loop the
first thing that's going to do is is
going to go for I and range of length of
X so it's going to go through all of the
coordinates and it's going to figure out
the distance from that coordinates to
the centroid so you can see here its
distance equals distance of XII comma C
and then it's going to cluster equals NP
argument distances and then clusters of
I equals cluster so we're basically
taking each one of those points and
we're assigning it to one of the
centroids and forming one of those
clusters we're not really sending it to
the century but we're signing it to a
cluster and then the centroid is center
of that cluster and then we take the old
values and you have to do a deep copy
remember we talked about that earlier if
you have a raise you can't just copy one
array into the other you have to do a
deep copy to have all the values moved
over so we're now taking the centroids
that we currently have and they're now
the old centroids and then we want to
find a new centroid value so we're going
to adjust that centroid a little bit
remember before we're moving the
centroids around until we got the right
fit so for this we do 4i
range of K again we're going through the
values you know three centroids or so
we're going we're going I with zero
through two zero one two is how that
actually reads so there's three values
in there and then your points equal X of
J for J in range length of X and then we
have if cluster J equals I C of I equals
NP mean points X is equal zero wow
that's a mouthful in there so let's take
a quick look at that and again this is
pretty under the hood deep stuff so if
you're just going to do a basic k-means
you can use the formula from the SK
learn module instead of programming it
yourself well we have going on in here
is if the cluster if your cluster in
your distances are connected correctly
and it looks at the mean the mean of the
points and the ax is equal zero then C
of I is going to be equal to that and
then we create a new error in there
again the error is based on the distance
and then finally we take the colors RGB
Y and CNM they just recognize this from
before a red green blue a little bit
different order red green blue yellow
and we take our figure and our axes
equals PLT subplots
and this is very advanced again if this
is a little confusing that's okay
most of this you don't need to do a
basic k-means we're just showing you
what's under the hood and so when you
take the figure and the ax and the plot
those are two different parts that you
can do in plots we can then plot the
points on to those and as we go down
here we create our points for J and
range of the clusters and then we create
our scatter points and we go and put
those on there just like we did before
from the k-means and then we also put
our markers so we know where our
centroids are so that's where the ax
scatter is and what we end up with is
these two nice maps a pressure
differences and you can see the
centroids are now done in black and the
blue region with the highest temperature
and lowest pressure will have high
rainfall so you'll see that nice blue
rain region in the bottom right that's
when they're gonna be worried about
flooding and comparatively the red and
green region will have lesser rainfall
so once you know which area or cluster
you're in from that data you can predict
what's coming in and how much to worry
about the rainfall coming in so you can
see in here a very one of the common
uses of weather analysis for using
clusters and you can certainly figure
out a lot of reasons in your daily life
if you start looking around and seeing
we're in business people want to be able
to cluster data together whether it's
marketing weather analysis whether
you're working out the logistics of
getting food to a restaurant all of
those come together and the k-means is a
very powerful tool for doing clustering
and doing machine learning and clusters
let's take a look at the key takeaways
for this
we studied machine learning workflow
where we learn to define an objective
prepare the data collect the data select
the algorithm train the model go back
and test the model see if that worked if
that didn't take a look at the training
of the model make sure that was correct
and if that still wasn't correct go back
and select a new algorithm to come up
with a prediction and a commercial-grade
output for our machine learning workflow
we looked at types of machine learning
supervised learning where we have the
data and the collections and the answers
to train our machine learning tools we
had unsupervised learning where it
doesn't know what the answer is but
based on its own ideas groups things
that are liked together and then we took
a quick look at reinforcement learning
finally we looked at types of supervised
learning and types of unsupervised
learning we looked at classification
regression we looked at clustering and
Association and then we took a look
under the hood of the k-means and what
that looks like in our use case with the
weather analysis thank you for joining
us today and for more information you
can visit w-w-w com
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here